Hello, this is Maria
Plummer, and this
lecture topic is the
pathology of hemorrhage.
These are the
learning objectives,
which should be the
same in your CPG.
And this is
the overview of
what we'll be discussing.
The ones in red are
obviously the ones I
will emphasize the
most. These are all
the bleeding disorders
that are important.
I want to emphasize
that the ones that
are not in red are
not unimportant,
but they are probably
covered in other
lectures and I'm
really going to
emphasize just the ten
that are in red and
just go very quickly
over the others.
This is a review
slide on hemostasis.
Remember there's a
primary hemostasis which
involves platelets and
is the platelet plug,
that's what it produces,
and the secondary
hemostasis is the
coagulation cascade.
Please review that,
that's important to
remember. and if you
like it in visual form
this is a nice visual
that can help you
look at it inside the
vessel so to speak.
Again there's the
platelet plug and then
there's the secondary
hemostatic plug.
This is the coagulation
cascade which
you've seen before. I
find this a little bit
too complex. I need
a simpler one and
so I figured this one
is nicer and basically
it just shows the
very simple the
intrinsic pathway is
the factors 8, 9, 11,
and 12, which are
measured by the partial
thromboplastin
time, and the
extrinsic pathway
measured by the
prothromba time,
PT, is basically
factor 7.
This is a simpler way
to look at it. Why
do we have two
pathways? The intrinsic
pathway is considered
slower, but it's
more robust than the
extrinsic pathway.
This is the fibrinolysis
process, which
you want to limit the
hemostatic process
to where the injury
is. We're talking
about vascular injury
here. You don't want
it to continue to
make a clot over, you
know, bigger and
bigger and bigger so
it obstructs the vessel.
So this is, We'll
come back to this
very, very briefly.
This is to keep
the hemostatic
process at the
site of injury.
I want to review
this, that the
PT and PTT and
INR, what are they?
The prothrombin time,
again, it's measured
in seconds, and it
measures the extrinsic
pathway, as I said,
basically factor
VII. And the PTT is
the intrinsic pathway.
The INR, you'll hear
mentioned, it's used
to normalize the PT.
and you compare the
INRs between different
places which have
different labs and use
different reagents.
And sometimes you'll
hear thrombin time
and bleeding time.
Bleeding time is
not really used much
anymore. It's an
old test, and it's
basically the time it
takes for a patient
to stop bleeding.
All platelet
disorders will have
an increase in
bleeding time.
and coagulation panels
include also fibrinogen
levels and d-dimers
which we'll talk more
about when we talk
about DIC and fibrinogen
is a glycoprotein
that's made by the liver
it's converted to
fibrin by thrombin and d
-dimers are the major
products of fibrinolysis
which also include
fibrin degradation
products and this will
be important when we
talk about DIC or
disseminated intravascular
coagulation. So the
major three problems in
the hemorrhagic diastases
or bleeding disorders
are either the
vessels are fragile or
there's a platelet
deficiency or dysfunction
or the coagulation factors
or some derangement
or a combination of
both, two and three.
I will concentrate
mostly on two
and three and very
briefly mention
one. So let's talk
first about the
quantitative
platelet disorders,
thrombocytopenia,
which is just plain old
decrease in platelets,
and then ITP, which is
immune thrombocytopenic
purpura, and TTP,
which is thrombotic
thrombocytopenic
purpura, and hemolytic
urebitic syndrome.
So just to all get
on the same page with
what petechia looks
like, it's basically a
little dot on the skin,
a little hemorrhage,
and it's very small,
usually less than
one millimeters. all
references may be a
little bit different
but this is a usually a
sign of primary
hemostasis which means
platelet problems and
there are small dots as
seen here sometimes
they coalesce and they
become bigger they're
medium size again
these measurements are
kind of variable but
let's say between one
and ten and sometimes
they're they're
palpable and when you
get a lot of big
bruisers or ecchymosis in
the dermal layer,
they're usually greater
than a centimeter,
and also they usually
indicate that there's
a coagulation factor
problem or a secondary
hemostasis problem.
So let's define
thrombocytopenia.
It's decreased in
platelets account,
and that usually
means under 150.
Normally it's about
150 to 450, depending
on the lab. There
should be another
zero at the end of
the 450,000 there.
And when we get below
50,000, even minor
trauma can cause
bleed and we worry
about bleeding during
surgery. When we get
under 20,000, there's
usually spontaneous
bleeding or there's
danger of it anyway,
and people can
get intracranial
bleeding. So we're very
serious about that.
In thrombocytopenia
alone,
the normal PT and PTT
are normal because
there are no coagulation
factor problems.
There's only platelet
problems. That's why
we have normal PTT.
Again, we discussed
petechiae. Also, remember
there can be bleeding
from areas like
nose bleeding and gum
bleeding, even heavy
menses. And so this
is really the whole
definition of thrombocytopenia.
What can cause
it is a lot of things.
Obviously this is a
chart from Robbins.
There are four major
things if you see the
decreased production
of platelets, the decreased
platelet survival,
which is the same thing
as saying increased
platelet destruction
if you will,
sequestration and dilution.
As you can tell by
the red that I
highlighted, we're going to
talk about those four
things mainly here.
So chronic immune
thrombocytopedic purpura
is a platelet problem,
is a platelet deficiency,
and why are the
platelets deficient is
because there's
autoantibody mediated
destruction of the platelets.
This is a diagnosis
of exclusion that
is the primary form.
There are secondary
forms that may be due to
lupus or HIV or
things like that. The
autoantibodies are directed
against the platelet
membrane glycoproteins
either 2b3a or 1b9
and they're present in
the plasma and bound
to the platelet surface
in about 80 percent
of patients. What
happens is the anti
-platelet antibodies will
act as oxidants that's
recognized by the
IGFC receptors and the
phagocytes will then
destroy phagocyte them
and destroy the platelets
most likely mostly
in the spleen and
that's how you get the
thrombocytopenia because
they get destroyed.
Again I mentioned
the secondary forms
include lupus HIV or
chronic lymphocytic
leukemia. In chronic
we mean insidious it
doesn't happen abruptly
and you will get that
bleeding into the
skin the pinpoint
hemorrhages purpura and
nose bleeding and gum
bleeding and but you
can also get things
like hematuria or
melanin or excessive
menstrual flow. The
spleen is usually normal
in size although the
sinusoids are congested
and bone marrow will
show maybe a modest
increase in megakaryocytes,
some immature.
This is not specific
because it really
just means that
there's accelerated
thrombopoiesis because
the platelets are being
destroyed and the bone
marrow is going to
react to that by
trying to produce more.
I mentioned the
petechial bleeds again
and you might see
large platelets in the
peripheral blood.
Why? Because those are
more immature and it's
a sign of accelerated
thrombopiesis. The
bone marrow is trying
to replace the
decrease in platelets.
So again, low platelet
count, large platelets,
PT and PTT will be
normal because this
does not affect the
coagulation factors.
When you try to test for
these autoantibodies,
apparently they
have low sensitivity
and specificity and
it's not clinically
useful. So again, I
would reiterate that
it's a diagnosis of
exclusion. Most patients
will respond to
steroids. Sometimes if
it's very severe, they
will do a splenectomy
because that that
will remove the place
that everything gets
phagocized. Of course
when you lose your
spleen you might
have an increased risk
of bacterial sepsis.
In acute ITP that's a
little bit different.
It's also it's
still caused by
autoantibodies to
platelets but usually this
is pediatrics. Not
always but usually
especially around two
to five years old.
And the symptoms
will happen very
abruptly and usually
about one to two
weeks after the child
has some kind of
viral illness.
They think that may
trigger the development
of antibodies.
The acute ITP is
usually self-limited,
which chronic ITP
is not. And the
acute ITP usually
resolves by itself
in about six months
steroids can be
given to children
if it's very severe
usually it's not
and some children
will go on to
a chronic form
of childhood form
of chronic itp
again sudden onset
pediatric patient
i just want to
say that the
platelets can get
very low under 20
,000, which is
pretty significant.
And the IgG
autoantibodies, as in
chronic IgP, are formed
against the platelet
surface proteins
and destroy the
platelets in the
spleen. And also the
liver is part of
where it's destroyed.
This is all I want to
say about Q-IgP. This
is a question. Please
pause and read the
question and hopefully
you have and this
is a question dealing
with acute ITP based
on the age and the
flu-like illness etc
everything you see
so the answer to this
question is c autoantibodies
against platelets
it is not decreased
production because
that's not the problem
here it's increased
destruction. There
isn't any deficiency
of the platelet
receptors, it's just that
they're auto antibodies
against the platelets,
and there's no viral
destruction, and
this is not leukemia.
So C is in Charlie.
I want to move on
to the thrombotic
microangiopathies. The
major two ones are TTP, or
thrombotic thrombocytopenic
purpura, and
hemolytic uremic syndrome.
For both of them,
you have excessive
activation of platelets.
When that happens the
platelets will deposit
as little microthrombi
in small blood
vessels with microvasculature.
Now what happens
is when you have
these intravascular
thrombi that will cause
something known as
microangiopathic hemolytic
anemia because the
red blood cells will
try to squeeze through
these areas where
there's some obstruction
and they will come
out fragmented and
platelets are being
consumed in making these
thrombi because that's
what these thrombi are
made of is platelets
and so therefore the
platelet count will go
down that's where the
thrombocytopenia comes
in again the PT and
PTT is usually normal
because it's not a
coagulation problem
traditionally a TTP has
been defined as a
pentad it doesn't, this
is not strict right
now, it's our criteria.
The pentad
would be fever,
pharybocytopenia,
microangiopathic hemolytic
anemia, neuro
problems, and renal
failure. And the cell
over on the right,
which is highlighted
by the black arrow,
is a schistocyte or
helmet cell, which is
one of the fragmented
RBCs that can happen in
microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia. Now, HUS
is also associated
with microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia and
thrombocytopenia, but
traditionally does
not show neurological
symptoms, and the renal
problems are usually
more prominent. Also,
it tends to be more
likely in pediatrics.
However, we know now that
distinctions are
blurred, and you can have
adults with TTP that
don't have all five
of the criteria listed.
And some patients with
HUS will have a fever
or some neurological
things. So again, it's
kind of blurry, but
let's think of it in
these silos for now.
So in TTP, the
pathophysiology is either
inhibition or
deficiency of an enzyme.
And that enzyme is
known as ADAMTS13.
If it's inhibition,
that means that somebody
has acquired an antibody.
If it's a deficiency,
that's an inherited
thing the atom TS13
is a metallic protease
enzyme and what it
does is degrades von
Willebrand factor multimers
if you have this
enzyme either deficient
or inhibited the very
large the large von
Willebrand factor
multimers will accumulate
and that in the plasma
and they promote
spontaneous platelet
activation
adhesion aggregation
resulting in a lot
of little thrombi.
And also in the areas
of high stress, that
will lead to small
vessel obstruction.
So low platelets,
again, because we're
talking about
thrombocytopenia, but normal
PTPTT. In this case,
there will be a low
hemoglobin because
the person has anemia,
the microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia,
which is causing the
presence of schistocytes
or helmet cells on
a peripheral smear.
They can do plasma
exchange, which
will remove the
autoantibodies.
TTP used to be once
pretty fatal and now
can be at least treated
in many patients.
So here's a repeat of
the Pentad. The one
thing I want to add
is that you might
see an increase in
the LDH. LDH is an
enzyme, as you may know,
that will be released
when the red blood
cells are fragmented.
So that comes out
of the red blood
cells, and that may
be also elevated, and
all these other things
we've discussed.
In HUS, another
platelet quantitative
deficiency, there's
going to be normal levels
of the enzyme, right,
because this is not
TTP, so there's normal
levels of ADAMTS13.
There are two types,
typical and atypical.
The typical one
is most likely
associated with
E. coli infection,
infectious gastroenteritis
that's caused
by a certain E. coli
strain, an enter
hemorrhagic one
known as 015787.
Usually the picture
is some undercooked
meat like a child has
a undercooked burger
at a fair or something
like that. What the
E. coli organism
does is to produce a
sugar-like toxin which
will cause endothelial
injury and as soon as
you have endothelial
injury we know that
provokes platelet
activation and aggregation
in the atypical
hemolytic uremic syndrome
that is associated
with defects in
alternative complement
pathway inhibitor
deficiencies and
inhibitor deficiencies
is a double negative so
think about that for
a second um that is
not as common as the
typical but i do want
to mention it okay
we don't really know
why uh there's this
platelet activation.
For typical HUS, you want
to treat them
supportively.
And to make the
diagnosis really, because
they are similar and not
just by symptomatology,
but you want to get
a shiga-like toxin
assay or an ADAMTS13
assay. And obviously
ADAMTS will be decreased
in the TTP, whereas
the sugar-like toxin
will be present in HUS.
Again, a repeat of
the labs that you'll
find and also realize
that certain drugs
and even radiation
can cause a thrombotic
microangiopathy like
HUS because they damage
the endothelial
cells. And this is a
summary slide with the
triad, if you will.
Actually, there's
also ****** diarrhea
usually, but again, I
want to emphasize that PT
and PTT will be normal
and the slide shows
many schistocytes here
or fragmented cells.
So this is a nice
summary chart from
Robbins which puts
everything in order I
hope and this is a
case question I'd like
you to read and
we'll talk about the
answer. This is
describing a case of TTP,
and it has all five
of the pentad present.
That's not always
the case and may not
always be the case
in certain board
questions, but what
is the mechanism for
thrombocytopenia? And
I hope you chose D,
deficiency in plasma
enzyme, ADAMTS
-13. For A, that
would be typical HUS.
This has nothing to
do with autoantibides
against platelet
receptors. The defect in
complement factor H
would be atypical HUS.
I'm just showing
this slide. I'm sure
you'll get a lot about
it in pharmacology
of heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia.
Sometimes there
are people
who take heparin and
maybe five percent
of them about a week
later, depends on the
source, whether what
exactly the time
will develop this
thrombocytopenia and it's
basically because again
of IgG antibodies
but this time it's
against a complex and
that complex is heparin
bound to platelet
factor 4. When the
binding of the antibody
to these complexes
takes place that activates
platelets and will
promote thrombosis
even though there's
thrombosis there's
thrombocytopenia that
seems paradoxical when
you think about it,
the platelets are
being used to make the
thrombosis, the clots.
That's why there's
thrombocytopenia and
these people may develop
a rash. So that's all
I want to say about
that and I want to
move on to qualitative
platelet disorders.
There are five listed
here. I will talk about
and emphasize Bernard
Suye and Glansman
thrombosthenia. In
Bernard Suye, which
is a real disease, the
platelet number is usually,
I say usually because
sometimes it can be
decreased, but for
our purposes let's think
that it's normal and
this is a qualitative
problem the platelets
are not qualitatively
doing well there is
an autosomal recessive
and the problem is
adhesion and you know
the platelets usually
adhere when there's
an endothelial injury
to the subendothelial
matrix when that doesn't
happen you don't
get a platelet plug
this is caused by inherited
deficiency of GP1b,
which is platelet
membrane glycoprotein
complex 1b, that is
a receptor for von
Willebrand factor and
you need that for normal
platelet adhesion to the
underlying subendothelial
extracellular matrix
which is exposed
when there's endothelial
injury. So this
decreased expression of
GP1b leads to decreased
adhesion and again
adhesion here is the
issue so you have no
platelet plug. Again
think of adhesion in
this particular case,
that's important.
This is a nice visual
illustration. The red
little half circles are
the GP1B receptors and
as you can see they
will hang on to the
von Wilbern factor and
if they're not there
there will be nothing
to hang on to so there
will be no adhesion.
We'll go on to the
blue semicircles in a
second but right now,
just look at the red.
So these patients
may have a decreased
platelet count,
but usually they're
normal. They'll have
large platelets.
As I said, that's
not specific.
And the bleeding can
be very variable. It
can be severe or doesn't
have to be. I want
to mention that
there's a test where
Ristocetin assay, which
will show no agglutination
with Ristocetin. Now,
what does this mean
well ristocetin is
an antibiotic which i
believe but do not
know is no longer used
it causes normally
von willeprin
factor to bind to
the gp1b platelet
receptor and that
results in agglutination
agglutination is
a word just comes
from latin meaning
glued together
this is measured by
an aggregometry thing
in the lab you know
how the platelets kind
of come together if
you don't have gp1b as
you don't in burn rca
you can't bind the
vwf can't bind to
anything so you will have
no glutination normally
uh they will do
flow cytometry you do
not need to know the
cd numbers but i just
want you to realize
that you know these
older tests are done
but to really be
confirmatory you want a
nice flow cytometry
test just to mention and
i'm going to show
this again about the
antibiotic risk of C,
and this is the one which
will cause von
Wilburn factor to bind
GP1B, so that it will
cause glutination,
okay? When you don't
have GP1B, it will not.
Glansman thrombasthenia
is another qualitative
platelet dysfunction,
which is autosomal
recessive and the
problem here is in
aggregation and the
decrease is in GP2b3a
which is another
platelet receptor.
Here the decreased
platelet to platelet
aggregation is what
causes no platelet plug or
a defective platelet
plug formation. The
platelets will not aggregate
if you test them in
the lab to ADP or
collagen epinephrine etc
because there is no
glycoprotein 2b3a which
is an integrin which
forms a bridge if you
will between the platelets
by binding fibrinogen
so again platelet
count usually normal
increased bleeding time
because it's a bleeding
problem bleeding is
often severe in this
case and you will get
agglutination with
ristocetin why because
you do have the gp1b the
thing that's missing is
the gp2b3a by missing
i mean also deficient
or dysfunctional.
So here's where the
blue semicircles come
in. They are the
ones that stick the
platelets together, if
you will, and if you
don't have them, you
can have adhesion.
The platelet will
adhere to the
endothelium, subendothelium,
but they can't
aggregate. They
can't stick together.
Disorders of platelet
secretion, acquired,
defective are really
three are the main one.
I'm just going to
mention storage pool
diseases. There are so
many of them. They're just
basically platelet
secretion disorders. The
aspirin ingestion,
that is therapeutic and
will be discussed by
pharmacology and uremia.
So this is just one
slide on fromboxane.
Remember that aspirin
inhibits the COX
pathway. So fromboxane
A2 is made by the
endothelial cells via
the Cox pathway and
when you inhibit it
of course the platelet
function is decreased
and usually that's
for the lifetime of
the platelet seven
to ten days. In
uremia you have renal
dysfunction you'll
have an increase in
nitragynous waste
products and the uremic
toxins will cause the
platelet dysfunction.
Okay so now we're going
to get to the clotting
factor deficiencies
slash dysfunctions
and the mixed platelet
disorders. By mixed I
mean mixed platelet
and coagulation problem
disorders and there
are four listed so
before i go into that
i just want to mention
about coagulation
disorders in general that
they may be due to clotting
factor deficiencies
or inhibitors to uh
the factor uh factors
which can happen in
hemophilia with factor
eight we'll talk about
that in a second.
These disorders will
have normal platelet
counts but PT or PTT or
both may be prolonged
or increased because
the coagulation factors
are assessed with the
PT-PTT as we learned.
With a mixing study,
normal plasma is
added to a patient's
plasma and if there are
any deficiencies in the
patient plasma, then
that would correct
with the addition of
the normal plasma. So
the PT-PTT will return
to normal. If there were
inhibitors, however,
that would not correct
because the inhibitors
would still inhibit.
The autoantibodies
or factor inhibitors
in the patient plasma
are going to still be
inhibited because of
the presence of these
inhibitors and that's
visually shown in the
right side picture.
This is again general
comments and we have
a picture here for
hemarthrosis which is
usually a manifestation
of a coagulation disorder
and as you can tell
it's very painful.
So in bleeding that's
due to coagulation
factor deficiencies
you get these large
bruises, hematomas
or these hemarthrosis
for example. You can
get bleeding through
the GI tract or
prolonged bleeding after
you get cut or after
a surgical procedure
like dental extract,
tooth extraction.
Hemophilia A is the
most common and the one
I want to emphasize.
This is a deficiency
of factor VIII. This is
an X-linked recessive.
What does that mean?
It means mainly men
or boys are affected
and homozygous females,
although 30% of
patients don't have a
family history. this
is the most common
hereditary disease associated
with life-threatening
I emphasize life
-threatening bleeding
because we're going to
have a different thing
to say about von
willebrand factor disease
or von willebrand
disease so these are
caused by factor 8
mutations and so there's a
deficiency of factor
8 you can get a lot
of different variations
in clinical severity
and that really
correlates with how much
factor 8 activity you
have to be severe you
really have to have
a very very low level
like less than one
percent. For those cases
that are symptomatic
there's going to be as
you can imagine easy
bruising, hemorrhage,
hemarthroses, excessive
bleeding can happen
after circumcision for
the neonate or umbilical
cord separation.
The thing is that
petechiae which usually
represent platelet problems
are usually not
present. Again I always
say usually because
there's always overlap.
So this is just the
table that shows
the X-linked
recessive trait of
hemophilia A and
remembering that 30% of
cases don't have
a family history.
Okay, so hemorrhage,
we worry about
bleeding and here
the PTT is prolonged
because of the
factor 8 is in the
intrinsic coagulation
pathway, right?
There's a normal PT
because factor 7 is
not affected, only
factor 8, none of the
other factors, so
the PTT is prolonged.
We discussed
hemarthroses. You need to
do a factor VIII
-specific assay to
diagnose this. And in
the past, this was, or
is still now,
traditionally treated with
infusions of
recombinant factor VIII.
Because of that,
about 15% of patients
develop antibodies
to that, and
those will inhibit
the factor VIII.
There's other treatments
that, again, I will
leave to pharmacology.
One historical fact
is that one of my
first AIDS patients was
an 18-year-old male who
was hemophiliac, who
back then we did not
have recombinant factor
VIII therapy, and
hemophiliacs received
factor VIII concentrates
made from blood,
and that's the way HIV
was transmitted. it
this is also true for
a hemophilia b which is
really the same thing
except factor nine
this time again it's
x-linked recessive ptt
is prolonged pt is
normal because nine is in
the intrinsic same
thing hemarthrosis um
almost everything is the
same so i'm not going
to go through this
again it's also known
as christmas disease
named after the patient
not the holiday at
least that's what was
told and this is not as
common and by the way
there is a hemophilia
c which is caused
by deficiency in factor
11 this is not x-linked
recessive it's
autosomal recessive and
it'll be also normal pt
and ptt because 11 is
in the intrinsic pathway
so 7 is not affected
again i'm just
mentioning hemophilia c
uh it's not as common
as a or even b so before
i go into one of
the most common uh
bleeding diseases uh von
willebrand disease let's
review this briefly
the most important
function hemostatic
function of von willebrand
factor is to promote
adhesion of the
platelets to the underlying
subendothelial matrix
which has been
injured by bridging uh
between platelet 1b which
we discussed and the
real the full name of
that by the way is 1b
slash 9 but don't
worry about that but
that's the full name if
you see that so these
are bridging interactions
between that and
von Wilber factor and
the underlying matrix
now factor eight
interestingly enough
is bound to and
stabilized by von Wilber
factor so that's
going to affect
whatever affects factor
eight is going to
affect von Wilber
factor and vice versa
von willebrand factor
function often is
also assessed using um
ristocetin agglutination
tests and as you
can imagine like
with bernard suey uh
syndrome there will be
reduced or no
agglutination because the
von willebrand factor
what you do is you
add the patient plasma
to normal platelets
that have ristocetin
and the ristocetin
basically would form
normally the bridges
but it doesn't when
it doesn't have the
von Willebrand factor.
So there's normal
platelet counts but
there's going to be
an increase again in
PTT but normal PT.
This is just a
visual, if you want to
look at all the
interactions of the
von Willebrand
factor, factor eight,
etc., this is a nice
way to look at it.
So von Willebrand disease
is the most common
inherited bleeding
disorder. I didn't
say fatal, but inherited.
There's about one
percent of the adults
in the U.S. that have
it, which is not
really a small amount.
It's usually mild,
spontaneous bleeding,
like nose bleeding. It
doesn't have to
happen right away in
childhood. it's usually
autosomal dominant although
there are rare
autosomal recessive and
there's a lot of variants
there's hundreds of
variants but there's
only a few that are
clinically caused disease
the three main types
are one two and three
now why am i mentioning
one and three together
and first is because
types one and three
von Willebrand disease
are quantitative
defects meaning that the
von Willebrand factor
is not present as it
should be in the right
quantity So type 1
is autosomal dominant,
and type 3 is autosomal
recessive, and type
3 especially can have
severe bleeding. So we
don't have enough von
Wilberin factor in
those in type 1 and 3.
In type 1 and 3 also,
again, I mentioned
prolonged PTT, but PT
is normal, and there
will be a wide
variability in clinical
expression. there will be
no platelet aggregation
or i should say
agglutination as we
mentioned and this is
the same picture you saw
before with bernard
suyer about the
ristocetin antibiotic
when this in this case you
don't have the von
willebrin factor so
that's why you don't
have the agglutination
type 2 von willebrin
is a qualitative defect
so you have normally
expressed normal amounts
of expressed von Wilber
factor, but there's
mutations and they're
defective. So that's
one of the main
differences. There's a lot
of other things and
subtleties. There's a
type 2a, a 2b. I'm not
going to go into that,
but I just want you to
realize that exists.
Okay, DIC, disseminated
intravascular
proagulation, a
very important
concept, and most
likely you will see
this at some point
in the hospital.
It can be acute or
chronic, sometimes
subacute. Notice the word
thrombohemorrhagic,
because it is a bleeding
disorder that also
can form thrombi.
What you have is
what's known as a
consumptive coagulopathy.
So coagulation
factors are consumed,
and so are platelets.
So with the excess
of activation of
coagulation, you will
get these thrombi
forming in the
microvasculature.
I want to emphasize
this is not a primary
disease. it's acquired
from and it's usually
there's something
else going on for the
main reasons and
these are not the only
four would be
obstetric complications
malignancies sepsis or
trauma like burns or
things like that so
everything is consumed
as i mentioned platelets
fibrin coagulation
factors and because
you get these thrombi
you can also present
with tissue hypoxia
or even infarcts in
certain organs, because
this is widespread
and also bleeding.
So there's two major
mechanisms that
trigger DIC.
One is the release
of tissue factor or
any other procoagulant
into the circulation,
which will activate
the coagulation
cascade, or
widespread injury of
endothelial cells. And
some examples here, like
procoagulants, for
example, placenta
in obstetra complications,
trauma, etc.
Certain adenocarcinomas,
especially GI
ones or pancreas, and
remember adenocarcinoma
means mucus
secreting or mucin,
that is a procoagulant
that will induce
it, DIC. And remember
that APL, acute
promyelastic leukemia,
has those big granules
that are procoagulants
that can cause DIC.
Any endothelial
injury that can happen
with microorganisms and
sepsis. Please remember
that TNF is a
mediator, one of the
mediators of endothelial
injury, and that is
implicated in DIC
occurring with sepsis.
Anything widespread
that affects the whole
body, so any deposition
of antigen-antibody
complexes like in
lupus or temperature
extremes or rickettsia
or meningococcemia that
would also be a cause
of DIC. So you're going
to have widespread
deposition of fibrin
thrombi, I should say
fibrin thrombi within
the microcirculation.
It's really the fibrin
thrombi and so there's
going to be obstruction
and that can cause
ischemia of many
organs and again with
a microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia because
there's fragmentation
of the red cells as
they try to squeeze
through the very narrow
microvasculature, which
is semi-obstructed, if
not fully obstructed,
in which case they
can't get through.
But there's also a
consumption of platelets
and clotting factors
and activation of
plasminogen, and this
will lead to bleeding. The
thrombi can occur in
many different organs.
They're listed here
in Oregon. If you do
in the brain, obviously
that's very worrisome
because you may get
microinfarcts. The
kidneys, You may have
renal cortical necrosis.
You can get microinfarcts
or fibrin thrombi
in the alveolar
capillaries of the lungs,
so you get pulmonary
edema. And in Neisseria
meningitis infection,
which is meningococcemia,
the fibrin thrombi
actually will
obstruct the adrenal
cortex vessels, the
microcirculation, and
there's going to be bilateral
massive adrenal
hemorrhage, and that is
known as Waterhouse
Friedrichsen syndrome.
DIC is sometimes also
if you look at it in
the acute or fulminant
form or the chronic
and normally the
acute is which is very
rapid is associated
with obstetric
complications or major
trauma and it's dominated
more mostly by
bleeding whereas the
chronic DIC is more
likely to be in cancer
patients and here it's
usually more likely
to be dominated by
thrombosis. But again,
the balance may tip
one way or the other.
The manifestations
we've already
kind of touched on, the
macroangiopathic
hemolytic anemia,
dyspnea, cyanosis,
these are all
from microvasculature
problems.
And of course,
circulatory
failure and shock.
DIC prognosis really
varies depending
on what's causing
it. And that really
is the treatment,
is to remove
whatever, or treat
whatever's causing it.
In DIC, you're
going to see a low
platelet count and
a prolonged PTPT,
both. Why? Because
the platelets are
being consumed to
make the thrombi, and
the coagulation
factors are being
consumed, both
extrinsic and intrinsic.
You will see the
schistocytes, as seen here,
because the RBCs are
damaged by the thrombi,
by trying to squeeze
through. You're also
going to have an increase
in D-dimers, which
are part of the fibrin
degradation products,
and a decrease in
fibrinogen, because that
gets consumed as well.
Now, sometimes fibrinogen
may be, in the
beginning, very, just
variably increased, just
because fibrinogen is
an acute phase-reacted.
But when DIC is full
-fledged, you definitely
have consumption
this is a nice uh i
think diagram of dic and
all the interactions i
i encourage you to look
at it it is from uh
i believe uh robbins
so just this person the
people need supportive
care obviously treat
the underlying uh
etiology you still have
to give uh the patients
fresh rose and plasma to
replace the coagulating
factors uh clotting
factors i mean these
patients will be
these patients will be
anemic will need rbc
transfusions and of course
they have thrombocytopenia
so they need
platelet transfusion um
and cryoprecipitate will
be important to
replace the fibrinogen
that's being consumed okay
so vitamin k deficiency
is one of the other
i talked about dic
being a that's a mixed
one you got both platelet
and coagulation and
the same thing here.
Vitamin K is a fat
soluble vitamin made from
intestinal flora. It's
found in leafy, green
leafy vegetables like
kale and spinach. Egg
yolk is not a vegetable,
but it's also found
in that. Vitamin K is
a coenzyme to epoxide
reductase in the liver
and helps with the
carboxylation of
glumatic acid residues
involving clotting
factors 2, 7, 9, and 10.
And notice seven is
there so it's both the
extrinsic and the
intrinsic arms of the
coagulation cascade and
this is just a visual
of the ends of what
vitamin k does and
the enzyme and the
coboxylation if you're
into that and biochemistry
and everything
so it will affect all
of these four factors
the way i remembers
2 plus 7 equals 9
plus 1 equals 10, if
that helps, and because
it does we'll have
a prolonged PT, PTT.
Normally the platelet
count is normal, but
you know again this
this can the problem
with this is that it's
both PT and PTT are
affected, they're
prolonged. Some examples
include the newborns
which do not really have
a vitamin K because
vitamin K mainly due
to the lack of the
GI colonization by
bacteria. They don't have
much bacteria in their
GI. It's also not
found in breast milk
and that's the reason
why we prophylactically
inject neonates at
birth with vitamin K.
Prolonged antibiotic
therapy sometimes can
because you're messing
around with the GI
flora that disrupts
vitamin k producing
bacteria and some
malabsorption disorders
also remember in
malabsorption you will have
deficiencies of fat
soluble vitamins which
would include vitamin
k okay so basically
we're done uh this
disorders of fibrinolysis
and the vessel or
abnormalities are
just passed through
this is the again the
i don't want to call
it a cascade but this
is a reminder of
fibrinolysis how you break
down the fibrin clot
and when you have
these disorders it's
usually because of
plasmin overactivity
and you can figure that
out by looking here
at what plasmin does.
Here you will have
again bleeding because
that's the problem
here increase in PTT
because plasmin destroys
coagulation factors
and all these other
things mentioned
here okay the vessel
wall abnormalities
there are many here
everything is normal
really the platelet
count is normal bleeding
time is lower pt ptt
is not because the
problem is in the
vessels okay and so
this is not usually
serious bleeding but it
can be it can be
more significant and
this is a list of
them which include
meningococcemia uh so
infections or rickettsia
drug reactions,
collagen vascular
disorders like
scurvy, Ehlers
-Danlos-Cushing,
Hennex-Schlannin-Purfer,
which is a systemic
immune disorder, and
something known as
hereditary hemorrhagic
linectasia, which you
probably would learn in
pediatrics. It's very
rare and it's osomal
dominant. So I just want
to mention those again,
just so we can be
complete about this.
Here's a summary slide.
And here is a second
summary slide and the
lecture feedback form
and some resources.
Thank you for your
attention. I know
that was a lot of
material. Please
feel free to reach
out to me and thank
you very much for
your attention.